-The president
is arguing in court
that Congress
can't investigate him
as Republicans wage a war
on reproductive rights.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-This week, it really
feels like we're seeing
one threat after another
to our system
of Constitutional democracy.
The president is vowing to block
all subpoenas from Congress,
his lawyers are arguing in court
that Congress doesn't have
the power to investigate him,
the White House Counsel
told Congress this week
that Trump would refuse
all demands for records
and testimony related
to the Mueller report,
and Trump is turning
the justice department
into a political weapon.
At this point, the next
"National Treasure" movie
is just gonna be two hours of
Nick Cage
trying to tape the Constitution
back together.
[ As Cage ]
I'm still missing a piece!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Earlier this week, for example,
Trump said he would resist
all Congressional requests
for documents like
his tax returns
because he thinks Congress
shouldn't be allowed
to see them.
-Why continue to block
these House Democrats
who are looking for information?
-Because they are asking
for things
that they're not entitled to.
I could ask them, I assume,
if they ask me,
I could ask them for
the same kind of thing.
They wouldn't want to do it.
-Yeah, they would.
In fact, several Democratic
presidential candidates
have already released
their tax returns
because they have
nothing to hide.
Do you think Elizabeth Warren
has a side hustle
selling hotels
to Russian mobsters?
[ Laughter ]
At most, I can see her
running a B&B
that serves breakfast
way too early.
"Be downstairs at 4:30
because the Cream of Wheat
goes fast!
The Trump administration is even
refusing basic requests
for information about big banks
that have scammed customers.
Yesterday, for example,
Warren grilled Joseph Otting,
the Comptroller of the Currency
during a Senate hearing.
Now, the Office of the
Comptroller of the Currency,
or OCC, is charged in part with
regulating banks
like Wells Fargo.
Warren asked Otting to release
information about the bank
which has had a series
of scandals.
Otting refused.
Let's just say it did not
go well for him.
-Will you commit to
publicly disclosing
the OCC's evaluation of the
"competence, experience,
character, or integrity,"
of the next Wells CEO.
-I will not.
-Why not?
-'Cause it'll be confidential
supervisory information.
-It's confidential
if you make it confidential.
The point is, you have
the legal authority --
-At this point in time,
I do not have plans to release
that information publicly.
-And what is the reason that you
don't have plans?
Why are you keeping this secret?
-As you indicated,
it's my prerogative.
-Okay. And our job
is oversight here.
-Senator Warren,
no one has been more tougher
on Wells Fargo than myself.
No one has been more outspoken.
-You mean at the OCC?
That's a low bar.
-I would disagree with that.
I find it insulting that you
would make that comment.
-Good.
-Oh!
What do you even say
in response to that?
"I'm insulted."
"Good!
I'm glad you're insulted."
"Well, I'm glad...
that you're glad
that I'm insulted."
[ Laughter ]
It's such a simple,
yet effective burn
that all you can do is
slink down in your chair
and hope she forgets
you're there.
[ Laughter ]
The president is arguing
that he can't be investigated
or subpoenaed,
and that Congress isn't entitled
to information about him,
and then there's the fact
that Republicans in Alabama
passed an inhumane
and blatantly unconstitutional
anti-abortion law
essentially inviting
the Supreme Court's
conservative majority
to overturn Roe v. Wade.
If fact, last night,
the governor of Alabama
signed the bill into law
and actually admitted
that it was unenforceable.
-The most restrictive abortion
law in the nation
is now in effect in the state
of Alabama.
The governor of that state
signing the bill yesterday,
which bans all abortions unless
the mother's life is in danger.
Doctors in Alabama who perform
an abortion,
if convicted, would face
up to life in prison.
-Planned Parenthood and the ACLU
are challenging states who have
restricted abortion
saying lawmakers
are passing these bills
only to benefit their parties.
-They know and say publicly
that these laws
are blatantly unconstitutional,
and they don't care.
-Tonight, the governor here says
while she signed the abortion
bill,
she also knows
it is unenforceable
because of Roe v. Wade.
-Think about that.
They passed a bill
they know is unconstitutional,
and they don't care.
Can you imagine how Republicans
would react
if New York and California
passed laws
just banning all gun ownership?
The NRA would send out
an all caps e-mail,
saying "Tyranny is here,"
Trump would tweet something
like,
"Gun grabbin' libs, not nice!"
with a bunch of weird
exclamation points,
and Sean Hannity
would scream so loud,
the screen in your TV
would crack.
Well, probably not your TV,
but your grandpa's TV.
[ Laughter ]
And it will not
shock you to learn
that some of the men
voting for these bills
have absolutely no idea how
pregnancy or reproduction work.
Take Republican state senator
Clyde Chambliss,
who was asked about the fact
that the bill does not provide
exemptions in case
of rape and incest.
Chambliss said that abortions
could only be provided
until the woman
is known to be pregnant.
Okay. Already, what?
Is this some kind of ancient
Alabama riddle?
[ Southern accent ]
The buffet is all you can eat --
That is,
until you get to the restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
Chambliss also said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
He also said,
"I'm not trained medically,
so I don't know
the proper medical terminology
and time lines,
but from what I've read
and what I've been told,
there's some period of time
before you can know
a woman is pregnant.
Wait.
You're not medically trained?
Because...
you [bleep] nailed it, dude.
[ Laughter ]
Did it really not ever
occur to you
to look into the terminology
and the time lines
before voting on this bill?
It strikes me
the only time lines
these guys think they know
is you have sex,
and then nine months later,
a stork shows up.
In fact,
that comment was so dumb,
Planned Parenthood actually
had to issue a fact check
on its Twitter account.
"When asked if this bill
makes an exception for victims
of incest,
Senator Chambliss said,
'Yes, until she knows
she's pregnant.'
Again, that would mean that
that person would have to get
an abortion before they know
they are pregnant.
That's not a thing."
It's not.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean...
Who was this guy's
sex-ed teacher,
a pole cat in a beer helmet?
But, of course, this isn't about
protecting life.
If that's what it was about,
then Republicans would invest
money in maternity care,
parental leave, universal pre-K,
or any number of policies
that would actually help
families raise children.
What it's really about
is depriving women
of their basic human rights.
And Chambliss basically
gave the game away
when he was asked why the bill
wouldn't apply to eggs
fertilized through IVF.
Chambliss said "The egg in the
lab doesn't apply.
It's not in a woman.
She's not pregnant."
Dude, you just admitted it --
"It's not in a woman,
so we don't care."
You said out loud
the thing Republicans
pretend they aren't doing.
You're like one of those guys
selling fake watches
on the street
and admitting it's fake.
It's not a Rolex,
it's a Polex,
and the numbers
are out of order.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now...
these anti-abortion bills passed
by multiple states
are blatantly unconstitutional.
In fact, the authors know
these bills will get overturned
in the lower courts.
That's the point.
They want them to get
to the Supreme Court.
And they're doing this now
because they think they've
finally got five conservative
justices on their side
with the appointment
of Justice Brett Kavanaugh.
You remember him,
the bad guy from
every '80s teen movie.
He looks like he should be
telling Michael J. Fox,
"A werewolf can't play
basketball!"
Of course, during
his confirmation process,
Kavanaugh repeated
all the usual nonsense
about how he'd be a fair
and impartial judge.
And honestly,
for the life of me,
I just can't figure out
what would make Republicans
think Kavanaugh
is on their side.
He's always been pretty,
you know, balanced.
-Since my nomination in July,
there's been a frenzy
on the left
to come up with something,
anything to block
my confirmation.
The behavior of several
of the Democratic members
of this committee at my hearing
a few weeks ago
was an embarrassment.
This whole two-week effort
has been a calculated
and orchestrated political hit,
fueled with apparent pent-up
anger about President Trump
and the 2016 election,
revenge on behalf
of the Clintons,
and millions of dollars in money
from outside left-wing
opposition groups.
This is a circus.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, holy [bleep]
That guy is a Supreme Court
justice now.
Can you imagine
what his questions
during oral arguments are like?
"I saw Hillary Clinton
outside my house last night
digging through my trash
as part of
a left wing conspiracy
to steal my identity
and make a mold of my face
so she can wear it as a mask
and rob a liquor store."
This guy accused...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This guy accused the Clintons
of orchestrating
a secret revenge plot with money
from left-wing opposition groups
to destroy him, and now he could
be one of the deciding votes
on everything from whether
Congress can investigate
the president to Roe v. Wade.
He sounds like he's auditioning
for a talk show with Alex Jones.
-They're demons.
They're frickin'
interdimensional invaders, okay?
I'll just say it. Make fun of me
all you want on CNN or wherever.
But everyone already
innately knows this --
These people are not frickin'
humans, okay?!
Hillary Clinton
is a goddamn demon.
Excuse me taking the Lord --
It's not taking it in vain.
She is a demon damned to hell!
Excuse me.
[ Laughter ]
-I like how he says "Excuse me"
at the end like he just sneezed.
For Alex Jones, an outburst
like that is just involuntary.
[ As Jones ]
Joe Biden is a secret lizard
who smells like sulfur!
Gesundheit.
[ Normal voice ]
Of course, throughout
his confirmation process,
Kavanaugh repeated
all the usual lines about
how he would supposedly respect
Roe v. Wade as settled law.
-Senator, I said
that it's settled as a precedent
of the Supreme Court.
It has been reaffirmed
many times
over the past 45 years,
as you know,
and most prominently,
most importantly,
reaffirmed in Planned Parenthood
versus Casey in 1992.
I understand the importance
of the issue.
that people attach
to the Roe v. Wade decision,
to the Planned Parenthood versus
Casey decision.
I don't live in a bubble.
I understand.
I live in the real world.
-Man, it's so weird to see
someone who's capable
of losing his [bleep] like that
suddenly calm and measured.
It's like seeing a crazy guy
in the subway screaming,
"Rats controlled by the
government are spying on us!"
And then he turns to you
and says,
"By the way, that jacket
looks fantastic."
[ Laughter ]
Kavanaugh was lying about
Roe v. Wade,
and we know he was lying
because he said
the exact opposite in an e-mail
when he worked for
the Bush administration.
-Somebody leaked
to "The New York Times"
and then to NBC News this e-mail
written by Brett Kavanaugh
in 2003
in which he argues explicitly
that Roe versus Wade
is not recognized to be
settled law
because the Supreme Court
could very well overturn it.
"I am not sure that all legal
scholars refer to Roe
as the settled law of the land
at the Supreme Court level
since Court can overrule
its precedent.
And three current justices
on the Court would do so.
-Man, I'd love to hear
Kavanaugh's explanation
for that.
[ As Kavanaugh ] Hillary Clinton
snuck into my office
wearing a mask of my face
and typed that on my computer
to frame me!
And Alex Jones is right,
she's a demon from hell!
Excuse me.
[ Normal voice ] Our system
of Constitutional democracy
facing one threat after another.
Congress should be able to
investigate the president.
Women should be able to make
choices about their own bodies.
I can't believe
I have to say that,
and if you're offended by me...
-Good.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪